so my ultimate prediction for part 9 of
Jojo is that it is going to explore a
more modern take on society
featuring protagonist Joshua Joestar a
new and upcoming youtuber on a mission
to become the most subscribed to channel
in the world so in honor of that
inevitability I recommend that we all
get into the spirit of things now by
subscribing to the new world view for
regular Jojo content uploaded straight
into your YouTube feed hello and welcome
to the new world review your source for
everything anime and manga and today we
are here to talk about the number 9 as
it applies to JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
so specifically some sort of you know
part 9 because being the filthy manga he
than I am and given where we currently
are in part 8 I cannot help but sense a
spectacular conclusion coming soon which
of course gives rise to the question of
a pastime and in regards to this there
is a great amount of strange
misinformation out there on the Internet
made who who would have thought but
there is one particular troll video that
has our key quote-unquote confirming
part 9 and it's obviously fake if you
actually watch the video but many people
don't for reasons and so there are those
who legitimately believe that it is in
the works or at least that it is in our
keys mind which it may very well be but
we are certainly not privy to that the
most solid piece of information I have
been able to find comes from comic book
calm which is already on to do be a
source at best they claim that during a
convention appearance in Italy
specifically at Lucca comics in game
2019 Eric he was asked about the
potential of part 9 taking place in
Italy to which he said that he would try
to write it in an Italian setting now
the problem I found here is that comic
book Rome don't cite their source for
this information and the links they
provide a great a clickbait that lead
you to a completely different article
although as a result I did get to see
some children doing in order order so
it's not all bad I guess not what I'm
looking for though definitely not at all
what I'm looking for and if anyone has
an actual sauce please do let me know in
the comments but in any case even if we
were to take this information at face
value it confirms absolutely nothing
there really is just a fun bit of
pandering and dispelling that is
important because before leaping into
any of the fun stuff we do need to
recognize the very real potential that
Jojo will conclude following part 8 and
there are a lot of good arguments for
and against that one of the more
commonly cited ones is our keys age
because yes he still looks like a
brilliantly healthy young man I mean I
seriously don't think I've ever seen a
more children generally delighted manga
carthon him but at the same time he is
currently 59 years of age at the time of
this recording and while I would never
call that old because my 59 year old
the would promptly hit me it is around
the stage way you need stop weighing up
what your life is and how you're going
to plan for the golden years and while
the exact age of 59 might not quite be
retirement ready Joe Joe Lyon also isn't
finished yet which will no doubt easily
take our key into his early 60s and then
the thought of another part being
published according to the same schedule
definitely take him into the seventies
range which is pretty Wow and that's not
to say that part 9 would have to be the
same length in format a 7 & 8 it could
be shorter and we will discuss that in
bit but at the same time it is still a
very confronting prospect for somebody
who has already given over three decades
of his life to this series and of course
a lot of that is due to the sheer
passion that Archy has for his work but
when you're 60 is alt and facing the
prospect of committing say another 5 to
10 years of your life to full-time work
then there are a lot of very serious
considerations to be had but moving away
from our key himself there is also an
argument to be made that a part 9 may
not be narrative ly necessary because
part 8 is currently doing such a great
job of condensing the entire alternate
gorge of us into one solid chunk I mean
we now have a fully fleshed out family
tree but so many roles feel that the
question mark very much becomes where
would you even go from here and why so I
think that if our key chose to retire or
maybe not retire but end Joe Joe after
pod 8 then it would give us a fairly
solid full stop having explored the
alternate universe significantly more
than I personally thought we were going
to when I first started Joe Joe Leon but
these are all incredibly boring and
pessimistic arguments so let's now
switch our thinking and delve into why
there could nation be a part 9 and the
first point is one that you've almost
certainly heard from every person who
explores this idea or even one that
you've brilliantly come to conclude
yourself which is that Joe Joe very
clearly operates on a trilogy based
system admittedly it's something of a
loose system but it's definitely there
so for example parts 1 through 3 are all
intrinsically linked to the stone mask
the pillar man and all of their
shenanigan area and what their ambitions
for the world have resulted in and I
highly doubt that they would have
predicted a flamboyant time-stopping
vampire but there you have it more so it
also connects the fabric of deere's
involvement in the series and there is a
good argument to be made that this could
be seen as the do trilogy despite part
twos distinct lack of deer and then in
parts 4 through 6 we focus very heavily
on the other mysterious stand error
which has varying degrees of importance
however this trilogy can be
characterized once again I do actually
but this time more in terms of exploring
deers legacy that he left on
world and love my god this guy's an
important figure but really everything
that occurs in these parts does have a
basis in do especially five and six and
then at the conclusion of six that not
only wraps up that trilogy but the first
entire Jojo universe and then cutting to
the alternate universe we finally have
one my dear is less involved and the
majority of the underlining narrative
seems to focus on the holy corpse which
was one of the primary goals of steal
boron as well as being responsible for
all of the bizarre happenings of mario
and jojo leon and given how part eight
is progressing with its unrelenting
focus on delicious fruit I don't think
that Jojo Leon is going to provide the
proper ending for this wholly co-op saga
and it just feels like we are itching
for a proper conclusion elsewhere and
I'm really hoping that we do delve into
it more because the alternate universe
mythology has captured me far more than
that of the First Church of us I mean
the stone mask business was always
interesting because ancient powers and
all but the arrows always felt kind of
met to me however the idea of the holy
corpse has me very consistently hooked
in part seven and eight I just think
that our key has implemented it far
better as a device than his previous
trilogies which is to be expected
he has grown exponentially as an author
and an artist which is another reason
why I'd be so keen to see him cap off
this trilogy in peak Archie form and I
guess kind of completing the magnum opus
that would be JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
there's just something so satisfying
about the idea of a set of three
trilogies rather than two trilogies and
a diptych but in order for us to do that
we also need some substance to explore
beyond the meta-narrative of the corpse
and given the way that the alternate
universe has progressed so far you would
think that well we need to find another
ultimate form of another classic Jojo
many of whom have already been detailed
in this new continuity the two notable
protagonist exceptions are Jonah because
he was a bit of a weird existence that
doesn't really fit into the alternate
universe in me not yet anyway our key
could very easily fix that with his
stupid degree of creativity but there's
also the potential of an alternate
Jolene who is a generation that has not
been showcased yet because alternate
universe Jotaro is too busy playing with
oranges and lemons to have procured
spawn as of yet that doesn't say that
those two are the only options though
because one of the biggest missed
opportunities from my point of view was
never really expanding on a certain
Shizuka Joestar it was adopted by Joseph
at the end of part 4 I felt so so sudden
that she was inserted to play a pivotal
role in part five or six but that's not
quite how things turned out however
there is plenty of room to give an
alternate universe Shizuka so much too
serve time in the spotlight then again
there's also nothing to say that we have
to dwell on other incarnations of past
giorgos an arc you might decide to form
an entirely new one or even pull
something of a pas date by having us
focus on a former antagonist like if
we're keen to have a bit of a golden
wind to revisit and maybe we could even
have an alternate good-guy Diavolo or
something in any case there is also the
looming question of what kind of period
and genre that a theoretical part 9
would be set in and this one is tricky
quite tricky because part seven and
eight skipped a ridiculous amount of
time which only leaves us with a handful
of options
essentially Jojo could follow its
established formula and take place in
the same year that publication began in
reality in which case we would be
looking at a narrative set sometime in
the 2020 decade which is intriguing but
it does once again narrow the possible
story genres available so what have we
covered so far
we've done horror fantasy Nazis
action-adventure slice of life gangster
mafia Prison Break Weston and mystery so
that's actually quite a fair bit but it
does leave us with some good options
remaining and a lot of these may sound
incredibly strange and off-putting at
first but then again I also remember
seeing steel ball run in a western
setting and I was just like oh really
and then it worked out just fine it took
me a grand total of like three pages to
adjust to the new setting and it came
with a huge advantage of being served
radically different to everything that
came before it it felt fresh so that was
a great benefit even if I wasn't a fan
of that genre specifically so it gives
me a lot of hope that Jojo can work onto
any genre condition so something that
Jojo has yet to explore would first of
all be a sports genre you know maybe
like we have our lead Jojo or some
plucky young player in some sort of Ball
related game and then the main
antagonists would be on an opposing team
and stand battles take place during or
around matches and yeah I know it sounds
really stupid on paper but on paper
everything about JoJo's Bizarre
Adventure sounds utterly ridiculous
another funky idea might be the genre of
true crime whereby out Jojo is some form
of investigator either privately or with
the police and we head into a seedy
underbelly story potentially featuring
gangsters our golden wind but with more
of a focus on the investigative side
maybe a seedy film noir style take on
the series with more cerebral and
investigative stands you know stuff like
Moody Blues I really enjoyed the idea of
moody blues and pretty much anything
that doesn't have a strict combative
focus although something much more
modern might be the possibility of
dipping into the superhero genre like
maybe the alternate universe of Jojo
reaches a point where Stan's become
public knowledge
and users have to register them and it
deals with all sorts of impacts that
that has on the world at large but
famous stand figures being hailed as
some sort of superhero and/or
supervillain like beings and you know of
all the things I've said out loud that's
the one that I really don't mind because
I do think the idea of stands somehow
becoming common knowledge would be quite
fascinating to explore and finally I
will also pose the idea of sci-fi which
i think is the most unlikely because I
he doesn't seem to enjoy gazing into the
future all that much but it really is
the only super broad category that
really hasn't been touched on at all in
JoJo's Bizarre Adventure and I am more
than ready to see Jojo in space or
something along those lines but how does
this all come together well even if part
9 is on the cards I suspect that we will
have to live with the idea that it is
going to be much shorter than its
predecessors or most of the predecessors
anyway parts 1 & 2 are pretty short I
mean that our key is going to be super
ambitious and part 9 may never be
finished I honestly don't think that a
short part would be a big problem though
because if you condense the core story
of every other Jojo part then they
actually do become very very short
experiences the thing that fills Jojo
but content are the stand battles and so
to make a shorter part you would just
need less stand battles and more story
focus it's a very simple equation and
certainly not something that I would be
complaining about so long as the stands
chosen to be included where the cream of
the crop interesting ideas from are key
but in the end as a greedy consumer of
manga and anime this basically boils
down to me want things give things now
please they may have only converted to
this old Georgia business very recently
but I do find the idea of this series
ending to be quite an unpleasant one to
say the least especially with so much
untapped potential in the hands of one
of the most creative mangaka that Japan
has ever produced but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts on a
potential pot 9 in the comments below
well even join my disco server and if
you're keen for some more charger
content and please do let me know by
subscribing to the channel for more
regular Joe Joe wonderous stuff
delivered straight into your YouTube
feed but for now this has been the New
World review and I'll see you next time